hi guys I'm Greg I'm Anita the channel
is getting more and more political by
this second oh yeah we're going to watch
them serious [ __ ] today on politics an
SNL Terry of Jake Tapper and Kelly Anne
calmly several people sent this to me
first one to send this video
Dylan ciraolo so watch the Jack tapper
SNL skit I know you guys have seen fatal
attraction yes Dylan we have indeed with
all the things the president tells
and/or Trudeau though cards were here is
always I'm Jake Tapper Fareed Zakaria
GPS is net and girl
right thanks everyone and great show man
with the words words think it was the
right call not to let Kelly in on today
thank you
I mean it's the White House offerors
just to make credibility issues yeah I'm
going to do one like a good night Mike
Turner I got tomorrow I'm good night
Jake hello there short
hahaha you manage a million what the
hell are you doing here I just wanted to
invite a minion stay this is how you do
it by breaking into my apartment
what was I supposed to do you aren't
answering my calls you changed your
number they're not going to be Ellie and
you made a bad feel that hot blackness
[Music]
again it's fine I'll do something else
I'm Roger really crazy once I do a free
commercial for among cashews like that
baby once held it's illegal
Oh a little ethics mile issues think of
the click you see I don't do this make I
do it to you you need me you need to
press me strong figure you need to
research by me and you can pull out the
truck funny yeah hey you know what the
trip with your frequent changes over
Kellyanne just stick your toxic it's
done
I can't be on be good okay Tom I know
you won't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Korean you going to look like hailey Mac
and they need to you okay okay you can
go under so whether you want you and
equip you want okay great thanks T
actually no I am just Kellyanne come on
Kellyanne time that I do only have three
lives left you in the noon Wow okay that
was that uh yeah was Mia impale
attraction inspired yeah I wanted to see
the boiling rabbit in the map I just
wanted in a fatal attraction again I
just wanted to see it man he said that
became his car I mean it would have been
cool to have that bathtub scene or just
shove and Killian going [ __ ] water or
obsessing I was bowled ingested sexting
live sketch comedy [ __ ] yeah Kate
McKinnon has me Kelly on Conway kind of
session yes you made it go to hutch man
come on I would like you you're missing
out Jack Tapper and you can have to
happen that that's it was happening AK
yeah so jacking it
you can be happening activism could be
definite like yeah this seems like a
real thing that Kelly on Conway would do
I think she would be a little more
psycho about it to be honest yeah Kevin
Conway it means a little bit psychotic
she believe is my shoes yeah she's a
little bit psychotic she's the only one
though out of the whole administration
that see like when everyone's talking
about you know like how it's not just
Trump who seems crazy and delusional
it's like the whole administration she's
the only one were when she's talking I'm
like I feel like you know this is
[ __ ] it's almost like they live in a
bubble where this world that they
created with their alternative facts and
all this it's real today though no le
encanta we may have a little inkling
that I'm really killing my [ __ ] but
I'm in the wine hallway I can feel like
she feel like she's she's know she's
lying
where's the very the other ones kind of
believe it yeah I really do denial is a
hell of a Geronimo's a hell of a drug
but I don't realize in denial hold on I
look now feel like you're not in denial
right here the whole Trump
administration is very much in denial
and I really like this - first I did - I
thought I liked rani hybrid boobie Perry
yeah I know sketches and taking it with
these two real people cuz killing I call
me does seem like she likes to be on TV
she seems like an attention [ __ ]
she seems a little bit like an attending
yeah we gotta be careful actually I
think 95 percent of the subscribers are
all supporters yeah no nothing we're not
trusting them so we're not saying to be
hard
yeah run supporters we're just saying
you know we're just giving you
alternative fact he jabbers pretty cool
like a real Jake Tapper it seems like
just the real deal he seems pretty cool
I got one of those like interviewer so I
could actually hang out absolutely Kate
McKinnon really made Kellyanne Conway
kind of sexy
yeah looks like Kate McKinnon was really
pretty in this weird way she can't
really she is really pretty really cute
and she's so like weird and quirky
which kind of makes me like finer more
dresses so attract like I can't do a
thing she does like a bit heat like that
but she soon what she's just worsen to
that at any given moment you know like I
don't have no idea what kate mckinnon
like outside of an SNL scare out of a
movie it'd be interesting to see I love
the SNL digital short yeah I didn't know
that this was a thing I didn't know they
were doing this yeah they do a short
film I go on every episode I haven't
watched as a known so long how do you
either there it need to sir watching it
consisted a they shaved them like a
legit short memory I know I was like wow
look at us and open it up but that
ending where becomes like body horrors
like your ring meet you on Canon yeah
yeah we're very I could see Kelly in
Conway actually being that in real life
she probably is before your killing I
calm relaxed stretch pants Kelly on
Conway that's all I have to say to you
I'm a hot older lady yeah yeah I feel
like she would be the kind of well like
a nice thick in the middle of bed and
start stabbing you in the jugular right
would mean she doesn't give me the
Sharon Stone vibe though yeah oh yeah
that's tricky definitely gives me the
plain clothes me gives me the glitter
she is more than right yeah I can figure
boiling some rabbits yeah definitely see
her boiling poor defendant leadership
alright guys well Espinel has a great
channel that's the only place you can
watch their videos they're officially
off of NBC breaking news here on the
real rejects train geneva channel
subscribe to me subscribe to the real
reject tried to Anita
dad there's mouse be it my boob and us
are and is the Anita stargazer Channel
and on the Anita star channel a lot of
Anita's and a lot of star happening on
my channel and uh Jennifer anything you
know I know you did
chatez Dylan again for Alan being the
first one recommend this video peace out
my brother says